brothels a hurry fled the war in Syria
four years ago after her home in Homs
was bombed she and her family now live
in this Lebanese refugee camp when she
first got to Lebanon what worked packing
boxes earning just four dollars a day
then an NGO called beyond rescued her
from that job and got her into a school
near the camp today the 16 year old is
about to head out to her poetry class
after years of trauma and uncertainty
Bob is beginning to find her voice and
she's learning to write verse for the
first time in her life knowledge Elia
the generation whose life is lost his
dreams have been broken by war we are
the generation that has grown too old
too soon this poem recounts the
challenges Bob faces as a refugee kate
famiiy has we're always attacking us
with words the Lebanese always ask who
are you where did you come from why did
you come here a two hours drive from the
camp the UN Children's Organization
UNICEF has organized an exhibition about
art and refugees at Beirut's civil war
memorial
this painting is inspired by the words
of our thoughts and feelings of dozens
of Syrian children and on display in
this exhibition in Beirut moved by the
poems and letters Syrian and Lebanese
artists have come together and are using
their creativity to describe the
experiences of these children of war
avant depths is one of the artists he's
tried to capture wild sentiments on
canvas this is not sadness this is this
is anger and and I I didn't want to show
the children as victims
the organizers deliberately chose the
memorial as the site for the event
Lebanon itself suffered through decades
of civil war there's nearly tore the
country apart
[Music]
civilians have been the main victims of
the conflict in Syria which has
especially targeted the country's young
many of the children that have written
these poems and texts have lived the war
very intensively they have lost their
homes their school sometimes their
parents back at the camp
fathers Ahuja is on her way to a
get-together with some friends she's now
taken up singing as well and says she'd
like to be a journalist or a singer when
she grows up
Walt has lost nearly everything but she
refuses to give up hope
[Music]